the US says Israeli settlements in the  occupied West Bank are not illegal in  last half-hour safety of state Mike  Pompeo announced that Washington is  softening its position on the issue  Israel's Prime Minister has welcomed the  move saying it rights a historical wrong  Pompeyo says he will leave the status of  the West Bank to the Israelis and  Palestinians to negotiate calling the  establishment of civilian settlements  inconsistent with international law  hasn't worked it hasn't advanced the  cause of peace the hard truth is there  will never be a judicial resolution to  the conflict and arguments about who is  right and wrong as a matter of  international law will not bring peace  this is a complex political problem that  can only be solved by negotiations  between the Israelis and the  Palestinians